it all happened over a 48-hour period
following reports the bank had liquidity
problems depositors rushed to withdraw
their funds and the bank simply ran out
of money
Regulators quickly seized the remaining
assets and took over
the bank is insured but this is capped
at 250 000 which is devastating for big
investors
we will get access to the 250 000 on
Monday but after that trying to get
access to the remaining capital is going
to take months so the reality is we
can't operate our business without
accessing some capital
the bank mainly service the high-tech
industry but its collapse caused a
ripple effect that spread through the
banking sector in all U.S banks have so
far lost about a hundred billion dollars
in market value
but experts point out that this collapse
is different from what happened to the
Washington Mutual Bank in 2008 that was
the largest bank failure in U.S history
and led to a massive economic crisis in
the U.S and abroad I don't think that
there's going to be a wider effect on
the whole economy in 2008 what happened
there was to do with real estate
Residential Mortgages ordinary people's
homes ordinary people's businesses I
don't think that's going to happen this
time I think it's much more contained
it's important to know this is not
credit related it's not like people are
defaulting at a high rate they're just
taking out their money so it's sort of a
self-inflicted prophecy
um you know if people weren't freaking
out it actually wouldn't be a problem
but despite these reassurances financial
institutions are nervously waiting out
the weekend hoping that when the markets
reopen on Monday the aftershocks off the
collapse will have subsided
Mike Hanna Al Jazeera Washington